io non riuscirò mai a farmi la barba in
modo corretto e ci tengo che voi questo
lo sappiate possiamo cominciare bene
attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi siamo su
una roba che non ho mai fatto e non so
perché si chiama ben di handling machine
quindi ben di e la macchina di
inchiostro è un horror famosissimo
capitolo le immagini movimenti già solo
che in italiano
c'è tera tira fuori di brut benvenuto
benvenuta
non sono un maschio grazie e un oro al
famosissimo e mi devo capire il perché
ciao sono fa vj quello che fai video
però non ho capito bene cosa debba fare
grafica di sto gioco e stranissima io
immagino di dover seguire l'inchiostro
per macchina linke però perché dove
trovarla macchina l'inchiostro cosa
serve sta roba
hai un filo le batterie capito si
partirà per tirar fuori l'ascensore
vediamo cosa nascondeva giu vecchio
amico
fammi vedere la macchinetta del caffè
formato gigante beh per fare cartoni ti
devi far di caffè accendere la macchina
a questa è la macchina l'inchiostro devo
scendere come si scende ansia parte
supporto a caesar aperte tutte le porte
ammesso sono aperte porte a caso va bene
grazie tratto della zuppa di bacon mag e
questo è pippo c'è pippo con il torace
aperto simpatico chi è che ride adesso
ma se uno psicopatico macchina
l'inchiostro potere principale va beh è
un italiano un po così però non c'era
anche prima questo non c'era prima
pippo è visto qualcosa tu hai visto che
la chiave inglese a me l'ha data grazie
classe pippo mi chiedevo se avevi visto
qualcuno mettere sta roba qua
comunque è simpatico davvero cioè si
muovono le cose molto bello ha la chiave
inglese che opera presa eccola mancano
delle robe tipo bo tutto il resto libri
vabbè comunque devo riparare la macchina
di inchiostro simpatico stai qua è per
l'amor di dio
madonna che anziché
ho tratto un disco in vinile mi durerà
per tutto il tempo sta canzone no
peccato che non era martin garics tanto
si è spostato tipo che ra qua
nel frattempo metto il disco qua
simpatico mancano 26 cose tipo un libro
una rotella l'inchiostro manca mister
velare il riquadro di prima mi
servirebbe dove fini si muovono le cose
qua no ma vaffan
cos'era ma cosa a correre la tua sorella
correre cos'era quadro è vabbè vabbè si
va io ho mollato la tastiera e niente
sono morto muoio min che kakà riusciamo
ciano l'uscita
eccola non ci credo sono cascato el'open
di drenare in chiave dai wired sommesso
veramente bene perfetto una situazione
idilliaca
no no no spero vi sta salendo l'inter
troppo veloce perché schiatto che ansia
su come me che l'ho scoperto solo adesso
questo è una colonna portante degli
horror quanto non me lo aspettavo
michael jones che ha fatto benissimo sto
gioco uno di più a livello di jobs che
uno dei quali fatti meglio cioè l'hanno
messo proprio dove non me l'aspettavo
mai aprì un nuovo cammino
il creatore cementiti ci ha mentito si
no vabbè stato nasce regalato non posso
difendermi famiglia era di nuovo se c'è
quel tipo di prima ragazzi come ragazzi
intendo pezzi di cartone che vi fanno
saltare dalla sedia vedete qua non
volevo salutare mi per carità di dio
permesso
c'è un cerchio alchemico
con demonio è svenuto per chi mi sta
l'acciaio alchimista the dead e cartone
capitolo 2 la vecchia canzone meno male
che lascia si è posizionata la sua sulla
bara trovare una via d'uscita beh
superiamo rimanere quasi bellissimo
piace tantissimo è veramente figo
utilità asse 9 lui ci libererà se con
lui intendi io proprio attenzione c'è un
bel mio amico dove assaggiare questa
quanto mi dispiace da 1 a 0 per parte
perché ci inchiostro comunque porco
demonio mag e che va beh c'era un tipo e
quindi ci sono ci sono tipi trova tre
interrotto dove litro in giro tipo qua
tanto lavoro distrutto un secondo fa
questo come è possibile eccone uno che
ho trovato passi così qua questo allora
se io ti spacco tutti spacchi non che
torni come prima ti spacchi è chiaro ma
stavolta la passi la prossima no
altra pulsanti pulsanti pulsanti
pulsanti eccolo qua manca ancora uno dei
colori red cau
apre il cancello tornano indietro let's
go
io con te non ho finito un periodo lo
dico è davvero buio qua è perchè negli
altri post invece era c'era una luce
incredibile le scale uscita come va bene
lo trovo io devo tirare la cosa non ho
capito ma maghette vabbè scusa a tutti
amici
non è che perché così è successo no
zitti bastava che no no no no ora o vi
ammazzo con l'ascia se l'è fatte in casa
vi ammazzo con l'asca e male che mi
fanno ti prego pretty ti prego ti
supplico niente perfetta dopo una
giornata di kakà sia aperta non si è
aperto un secondo fa registrazione bene
e qualcuno mi qualche doppiatore mi dà
una mano per favore del mini dal angels
dai viking minimi e formali basta
minchia non è che posso fare tutto da
solo siamo in quattro non è che posso
suonare tutto io e erano lì anche prima
signori va beh allora ma scusami cio dei
problemi io cosa
ok non c'erano prima l'importante è
saperlo prima donna a questa sa perda il
violino trema in contrabbasso canta i
tamburi suonano il violino urla
ok quindi violino contrabbasso tamburo
violino violino contrabbasso tamburo
violino
e quindi sbloccato degli hueco ma va a
cagare va sei anni per entrare dentro
sei anni dovete morire voi e i
contrabbassi zingaretti sanguinari two
way for his rivals coming verri su non
me la traduco trova la seconda va la
seconda va beh vabbè vabbè vabbè
hai capito solo tu come come prof vabbè
non fa niente una bella giornata portico
demonio morto ieri i fatti vostri grazie
ai gentili molto gentili che è successo
qua da noi e roviaro slim sinners c'è un
tipo con un cappello però lascia la
valvola in mano mi lega valvola per
cortesia salve
mica mi dà la valvola per favore mi dai
la valvola per cor ten si stava tenendo
la valvola l'ho visto io mi dai la
valvola per favore la valvola valvola
morgana t'ammazzo la valvola aspetto che
forse riesco a farlo ma soprattutto dai
l'ho colpito stavolta quelli la faccia
di gran testa a chi è più forte
mamma mia mi sono diplomato per questo
bel cappello l'avrei detto anch'io sai
ora questi così lavori pure preso non so
se lo puoi prendere però non è che mi
serva tantissimo let's go eccola qui la
mia valvolina vai dalle scale
potevo arrivare le scale esce anche
satan dal terreno ma quelli sono
dettagli permesso
vorrei uscire ma tirato una pedata nei
maroni che è successo o gesù cristo
ahi lui semi lorenzo ascolta no no
quella roba lì la uso io in teoria
potresti evitare di darmi fastidio
perché poi si è riempito di inchiostro
grazie a dio ha posato lascia almeno
bello almeno non è out la stiamo
arrivando qualcuno di strano demo
nell'inchiostro oh mio dio
raga ma lascia la cia ok perfetto
perfetto perfetto
devo scappare prima che lui avvocato
qualcosa non ho capito cosa ma devo
scappare fortissimo la donna al volto
tanta gente perché perfetto vai vai
scappa scappa scappa se non ho ben
capito dove cosa evocato ma evocato
qualcosa questo adesso ho capito via via
via via via via via via via velocissimo
però che ansia sono andato contro un
muro c'era vedo una luce sono morto chi
era il tipo che mi è spuntata una certa
sono vivo ok non e non sono vivo non
sono di smettiamola di cercare di non
sono vivo no vieni qui ha fatti vedere
noi
pippo ma non ci credo mai e rivivo mano
boris ma è mai visto un cartone vita due
siamo su pendii and hate machine
siamo sul secondo episodio eravamo
rimasti ragazzi al capitolo 3 c'eravamo
arrivati al capitolo 3 su e giù e la
cosa fighissima di questo capitolo è che
c'è l'ultima volta che l'ho fatto era
spuntata una certa pippo questo questo
pippo però come personaggio vero e
proprio cioè senso girava proprio in
piedi capito quindi non non ho capito
bene se mi ha ammazzato se è un mio
alleato non capito niente però vabbè
l'obiettivo visto ciò che trovare
un'uscita comunque ancora non l'ho
trovata promisi sveglio imposti media
fuori a di mangiare i calamari cosa
succede qua eccolo ha sì ma da allora
non lo sono sognato io ma se veramente
magro e basso più basso di quanto un
aspettarsi ciao cucino io stai
tranquillo boris faccio io che quando
cucino io tutti si leccano i baffi poi
muoiono propone la conseguenza che
ancora non son riuscito a risolvere ah
ok perfetto quindi devo cucinarla
proprio va bene io stavo scherzando
prima un componere a questa zuppa e samp
o di inchiostro secondo me proprio
cucino io
usalo quello il cucchiaio lì grazie ma
se serio che volevi veramente che ti
cucina siro
ora che ti sei appena ucciso questa cosa
però va bene ne stai lì e buon appetito
noto detto stai lì cosa fa la torcia
ancora non ha avuto la ti sto gioco
vieni vieni vieni pippo boris scontri a
che cuor di leone sto ragazzo vieni
vieni all right vediamo se le scatola
rabbia riuscita con pippo e boris
parla con bourifa e dimmi
se un grande famiglie del se ho marciato
qua sto pezzente ma [ __ ] la torcia è
andato via
trova una nuova uscita a no che mi ha
aperto la porta ragazzi ma che bel posto
molto cari mi piace questo gioco posso
boris boris liri 4 timbrato il
cartellino e 6
dov'è finito il disgraziato maledetto a
c'è una porta lama di melo prima nuova
gamma un'ora per trovarlo hi fi passare
slow fish guaita gol e una pollastrella
va bene ma va angolata per sua sorella
con la stella ho avuto luogo che capiti
ho capito di leggere pollastrella dalla
bajocca ci vediamo non ci vediamo che
stai tu stai diamond è in cielo da che
parte vado vado ovviamente dove c'è
scritto the demon se vado dall'altra
parte lo so già che me la prendo di più
nei camp ranzi
insomma proprio di per certo permesso
sai che non sto ben capendo dove sto
andando ma sto andando a precisati poi
nascondere ma quindi visto che è proprio
ma tema pippo in tutto e boris come te
gravi
tutto questo dove è finito ecco no no tu
l'altro l'altro mio amico tu non puoi
anche morire eccolo armatevi prendi il
tubo di boris by così lui non ce l'ha
l'arma so solo io
perfetto di stupri morire io no ma hai
notato che hanno tutti hanno fatto i
pupazzi formato gigante non sei contento
quanto lungo sto cavo ma poco demonio
dai sei uscito dal quadro nuovo con
coriste il quadro si chiama forma non fa
danno ci metto sei ore per spaccare
qualcuno
l'altra one shot a va dai tira
girato chi male mi ha fatto appuntamento
con la visita alice angelo nel livello
alice angelo si chiama se qualcuno di
voi che mi serve si chiama alice angelo
me lo scriva vi prego alice angelo nome
bellissimo data dovrebbe essere in
inglese eliza in gel vero mi sa che
hanno tradito caduto anch'io per
l'italia non sono sicuramente non vieni
che hanno tradotto male sto gioco pieni
quasi seguitemi cioè seguitemi seguìto
dannato eccola viene neanche tanto dove
c'è la luce lei una pollastrella si si
lo so che una parola strana è già detto
no non correranno ancora può trarsi
l'inganno può essere una bella gnocca va
affidati che ciò dei problemi non corre
infatti questo coso qua non fanno niente
world ma che sa ma non eri tu quello del
primo episodio allora ce ne sono tanti
ti fa schifo sta roba che sta vedendo
c'è scusa non volevo signorina facciamo
le cose fatte bene allora si calmi si
calmi la prego quel canto di questo è
quello che vuoi tipo quali è seguire gli
ordini dell'angel ritorno all'ascensore
va bene non ho proprio voglia di seguire
gli ori sta tizia però va bene non fa
niente perché io sento il rumore sento
sospirare tantissimo
cos'è il demonio pedalato sto salendo
tanti dove sto andando e un'ora che
salgo scale
cos'è dimmi che boris non s'è mosso e
che è rimasto dentro ti prego
eccolo ti prego basta ho fatto a piedi
perché sono una persona in forma io
siringa prendi tre inchiostri molto
molto spessi va bene che è veramente ma
posso fare del male i nemici con questa
infilo nella gente viene boris sono
giocattolo guarda allora devo siringare
la gente questa è una cosa che so fare
molto bene mi sono sempre allenato nella
mia vita ma adesso che devo farlo io vi
assicuro che non uscirà mai più nessuno
ecco come lo ha detto ma mai a nord
stopiglia scopi io sono fa niente di
danno sta roba
porca vacca ma sono questi tizi che devo
colpire esattamente no perché non ne
sono sicurissimo
madonna è brutto spotivo l'ho preso l'ho
preso ho preso cosa ho preso uno di quei
che va bene me ne servono 3 ho ammazzato
un tipo veramente brutto per farmi
notare va bene ma devo single siringa
rage snella che kakà
vuoi stare calmo un attimo devo
siringare la gente beh questa è una roba
proprio family friendly ma che questo
rumore orribile ora non so se se n'è
accorto amico mio non so se te ne sei
accorto ma c'è una roba in testa che non
è proprio il massimo
intanto picchio sarò ma dove vai
nel sondaggio cioè peccato poverino per
favore portavi indietro il mio in
tracciatore certo savoia stavo pensando
ma guarda al mcdonald di un sandwich
solo quando lo dici topino tanto guarda
te la vuoi riprendere st fottutissima
siringa che non mi serve a niente the
the top la bussola butto dentro ciò di
mor tubo ascolta e boris dobbiamo andava
al lavoro al presidente supermario ecco
quello che altro io colpisco la gente la
gente perde inchiostro va bene e io sono
espertissimi in trovare nuclei di
valvole quindi si sa mai
avete bisogno mi date un colpo di
telefono e io arrivo turco demonio lo
yen
ma che si e poi ho preso nucleo di
valvola era quello questi sono i tubi
d'inchiostro nel livello chi va bene
uscito un tizio non so se questo il
nucleo del che cosa devo via faccio
l'idraulico di inchiostro a tempo perso
per arrotondare il fatto che youtube se
pagato e quindi devo devo fare stava
bene
oddio senti infatti un po ma piuttosto
dammi la mano non so ti pago ci siamo
grazie sono piccolo corriere ma che mai
preso per amazon top top c'è altro altro
devo fare qualcos'altro
prendere o ho finalmente distruggere
tutti i tagli di ben di raga
ci sono dei problemi tra l'altro su
questo piano non so se ve ne siete
accorti salve porca eva è morto subito
lascia è veramente forte ragapiano
l'andata subito maroni spacco tutto in
un colpo solo guardava lascia troppo
forte
chi è questo a regà 9 comminato anche
stati chi è questo qua ciao porco
demonio dove ragazzi e siccome la
telecamera avuto un problema tanto per
cambiare l'altro la faccio qui subito
dopo che ho finito di giocare che c'era
un po di kakà quindi ho preso la
macchina e nostro guidando io ovviamente
queste guidavo io era un ulteriore
problema spero vi sia piaciuto ben di è
veramente fighissimo un po meno tipo
boris cioè nel senso lui e sta fermo non
fa niente vabbè comunque ragazzi spero
vi sia piaciuto continuare una prossimo
episodio
fatemi sapere se consiglio robe che
faccio magari male che magari riuscite a
spiegarmi bene nei commenti tipo come
trovare gli oggetti e questa auto loro
sto facendo lunga propositiva ma dieci
minuti e se vi dove piaciuto la seta
certamente piace che ci chiede incidiamo
l'anno prossimo video c'è il rosso
perché ci stava macchina davanti che fa
i fari beh beh youtuber professionista
[Musica]